I xeni I really loved your video um I'm
i would like to respond to it because I
sort of figured asking the same way i
would look at refugees in london and i
think that one of the greatest problems
that we have is our difficulties in
receiving and and tolerating anyone
who's different from ourselves we have
so many boundaries in the world and i
think that one of the only ways that we
can start time out those boundaries by
we were talking to each other we need to
listen to each other stories that's
bottom line really and and art and
culture can help with have a great deal
but we also need to encourage businesses
and politicians for listening in
slightly different way because this
young kid from china on my possession
yesterday you said remember politicians
who need to lose their is is something
from just decorations in the sense of
their home and I just thought that was
brilliant so I heard you and I'm working
very hard myself to to melt those
strange wall so we put up your tween on
each other and I think that that kind of
work can be done on the ground every day
just by turning around someone who looks
occur to you and saying hello what's
your story